Sex is awesome, right?
Wrong.
Turns out sex might be great for everyone
except Grandpa.
If thinking of your grandparents having sex
is weird, just remember, you’ll be that
age some day...so listen up, ya old boners.
Hi everyone, it’s Jackie.
And I’m here to tell you that you should
definitely have sex.
Ok, we’re not medical doctors and you shouldn’t
necessarily take our advice on that, but there
are many studies out there detailing the health
benefits of sex.
Although... if you’re an older guy hitting
the town, you might want to simmer a little.
The Journal of Health and Social Behavior
recently published a study about the effects
of sex on older people, specifically between
the ages of 57 and 85.
It showed that older men who had sex at least
once a week, ended up much more likely to
later experience cardiovascular events, like
a heart attack or stroke, than men who were
sexually inactive.
Researchers also found increased levels of
hypertension, rapid heart rate, and elevated
C-reactive protein, which would indicate inflammation
in your body,.
But this didn’t hold true for women.
They did not see these same risk factors,
and in fact, women who reported having enjoyable
sex actually ended up with lower risk of hypertension
five years later than those who didn’t enjoy
themselves.
Hypertension is a fancy scientific way of
saying high blood pressure.
Turns out men and women aren’t the same.
For example, when experiencing stress, and
yes, sex can be a stressor, men are more likely
than women to report increased blood pressure,
type 2 diabetes, heart disease and heart attacks.
This happens because the male body responds
to cardiovascular stress by increasing vascular
resistance which is the force that opposes
blood flow.
This can lead to an uptick in blood pressure,
but these changes don’t seem to show up
until the sun is going down on your life.
However, the female body responds with an
increased heart rate -- therefore an increased
amount of blood that the heart is pumping.
And this may explain why some older women
end up experiencing decreased hypertension
if they remain sexually active.
Scientists theorize that since older men may
have to exert themselves more than younger
men, the increased activity could create more
stress on their cardiovascular system while
trying to climax.
So medications like Viagra may not be as helpful
as you think.
Now before you start thinking that the 40
year old virgin may have the right idea, remember
that sex can also be healthy and good for
you.
Phew!
The older men in that study who had sex, but
less frequently (only one to three times a
month), actually had lower risks of certain
cardiovascular disease factors.
So the amount of exertion matters.
Another study out of Harvard showed that men
in general who ejaculated 21 or more times
per month had a 33% lower risk of prostate
cancer.
There is also research showing that sex can
improve your mood, your quality of sleep,
minimize your stress levels, help you look
younger and, who are we kidding, it’s just
fun.
So...if you’re an older man having sex,
you might want to watch yourself.
But if you’re a women at any age, I say
get it ladies!
Now If you want to get more of this face,
head on over and subscribe to my Youtube channel,
NewsyNews.
Sometimes I even find funny things to say
about sex.
So, given how much energy is involved, is
sex actually exercise?
Good news.
We covered that in this video here.
What else do you want to know about sex?
Tell us in the comments and don’t forget
to like and subscribe to DNews so you can
watch new episodes every day of the week.